bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur arte france alors cette
convergence des luttes quand on voit que
les cortèges de manifestations
distinctes sont rejoints est-ce qu'on
s'y approche wascon et la convergence
des luttes
oui parce qu'en réalité la question
c'est la liberté aujourd'hui que ce soit
sur le cas du coc guide août ce soit sur
cette nouvelle loi séparatisme on a une
atteinte fondamentale à nos libertés
et donc je comprends qu'aujourd'hui les
français veulent manifester meules sous
poser finalement à tout certain qu'ils
sont manifestes et qui sont
disproportionnées nos libertés
fondamentales
on le voit aujourd'hui dans la rue on le
voit aussi sur twitter avec le fameux
hashtag je ne me confinerait pas les
acheter à deux et des manifestations qui
sont complètement compréhensible alors
beaucoup de revendications à pour ces
manifestations aujourd'hui dont une le
retrait total de la loi sécurité globale
quel regard portez-vous justement sur ce
projet de loi moi j'ai un regard très
critique qui parce qu'en réalité cette
loi ne sert strictement à rien si vous
voulez aujourd'hui lutter contre
l'islamisme radical parce que c'est là
la vraie question la question du la loi
séparatisme aujourd'hui en débat il faut
assimiler les gens qui arrivent sur le
territoire national il faut qu'il soit
complètement dans la communauté
nationale c'est à dire qu'il faut à la
fois réglé le problème des banlieues
mais il faut aussi lutter contre
l'islamisme radical
et il faut expulser de france les gens
qui ne respectent pas nos valeurs
républicaines et qui n'ont pas la
nationalité française
de surcroît je note une chose c'est que
dans la proposition dans la dans le
projet de loi séparatisme vous avez des
dispositions qui en fait ne vont faire
que rappeler ce qui existe déjà
je veux pour exemple est aujourd'hui une
association qui viendrait à troubler
l'ordre public pu être peut être
dissoute
une association du moins très cher de
culte qui viendrait aujourd'hui à
vouloir s'en prendre à la république ou
à demander à des gens prendre les armes
par l'article 35 de la loi de 1905
vous pouvez instruire vous pouvez
inculte et ce prêcheur qui veut
atteindre à la république donc en
réalité tout ce qu'on nous aime
dans ce set pour ce projet de loi n'est
rien en réalité ça ne dissimule qu'une
seule chose c'est que l'état est
incapable aujourd'hui de s'attaquer
réellement aux problèmes et j'en lieu
d'être dans l'action
il est dans la légifération et moi ce
que je ce que je reproche aujourd'hui au
gouvernement c'est au lieu d'agir
il préfère faire des lois il préfère
faire du verbiage ils préfèrent nous
occuper avec des faux débat alors qu'il
a déjà tous les outils juridiques pour
aujourd'hui tous voir réellement
résoudre le problème de l'islamisme
radical
alors ça veut dire qu'en france
aujourd'hui on légifère trop sale en vo
mais bien sûr qu'on lisait faire trop si
vous voulez les outils existent déjà
gelé dit une association qui viendrait à
vouloir porter atteinte à la république
ou une religion qui via une association
voudraient s'engager contre la
république pour être dissoute
la loi existe le cadre légal existe le
problème c'est que au lieu d'avoir un
ministère qui agit on a un ministère qui
n'osent pas bouger et qui préfèrent
faire de nouvelles lois faire de la
communication
et ça c'est complètement mauvais parce
que en même temps on porte atteinte à
nos libertés fondamentales
aujourd'hui par exemple l'enseignement
privé est un enseignement qui fait
partie de la liberté fondamentale
d'enseignement c'est à dire que vous
avez des gens qui veulent enseigner à
leurs enfants chez eux qui veulent
passer par certains établissements qui
respectent la république et par le
système déclaratif qu'on va mettre en
place
eh bien on va porter atteinte à cette
liberté fondamentale alors qu'on
pourrait déjà aujourd'hui faire ferme il
depuis la loi de 2018 on pourrait fermer
des écoles coraniques qui insulte à des
enfants des valeurs qui sont contraires
à la république dont torriente menée
dans la gesticulation et moi ça me
dérange pourquoi parce que on voit qu'on
a une partie de la classe politique qui
est ravi de voir cette nouvelle loi qui
ne servira à rien et en même temps qu'il
sert à monsieur macron pour lui
permettre de faire semblant d'agir
contre le radicalisme religieux alors
qu'aurélie ne fait strictement rien et
c'est ça qui est proprement scandaleux
alors là séparatisme projet de loi
sécurité globale suppressions d'emplois
la colère semble se généraliser en
france quelle réponse doit apporter le
gouvernement selon vous pour tous ces
secteurs à l'heure
le rappel de la crise sanitaire lors de
la crise et lutter toute façon c'est un
problème global depuis des années c'est
à dire qu'on a une chute de notre
économique est connue depuis très
longtemps parce que notre état ne défend
pas l'industrie ne défend pas l'emploi
français aujourd'hui ce qu'on est en
train de vivre avec le comique c'est
qu'on ferme les restaurants on ferme les
six mêmes un an ferme les opéras on
ferme tout alors qu'on peut aller dans
le métro à 8 heures du matin ou à 18h et
s'entassent et donc on se rend compte
que c'est totalement aberrant moi je
suis pour une chose très sain je suis
pour responsabiliser les france c'est à
dire on vous dit en français font porter
de masque on dit aux personnes
vulnérables aux personnes âgées faut
essayer de vous confier pour vous
protéger mais on laisse faire la vie
économique
c'est à dire on retrouve les restaurants
on trouve les cinémas on trouve les
lieux culture on relance notre activité
économique on relance nos universités
parce qu'on on a énormément d'étudiants
qui sont aujourd'hui dans une détresse
qui est incroyable sur le plan social
est sûre et le plan économique on
relance notre pays parce que première
cheveux première premièrement on ne sait
pas si simplement si on reprenait comme
avant on aurait plus de morts ont été
tristement rien et moi mon avis on
n'aurait pas davantage cm le masque et
si on respecte les gestes barrières tout
en restant tout en allant si mes mains
en allant dans l'université ou dans les
kops que vous voulez donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les mesures sanitaires
font plus de désastre que le collier de
lui-même et sur le plan de la sécurité
globale du projet de la sécurité globale
il faut arrêter avec ces attaques y sont
disproportionnée à la liberté
d'information et à la liberté
d'expression
là on a changé l'article je sais plus
quel article c'était dans le projet de
loi sécurité globale aujourd'hui c'est
un article je sais plus combien dans le
loi de séparatisme ou en fait on va
interdire de filmer les policiers les
gendarmes lorsqu'ils sont en train de
faire une mission de maintien de l'ordre
lorsqu'ils sont en train d'agir or je
veux rappeler une chose c'est que la
police comme la gendarmerie sont des
services publics et en tant que service
public
ils sont soumis à une obligation simple
c'est celle de transparence c'est-à-dire
que tout citoyen peut filmer un policier
un gendarme parce que c'est un service
public
alors après utilisé l'image pour porter
à l'atteinte de tels ou tels policiers
c'est interdit par la loi c'est déjà
interdite il faut que les magistrats
fassent leur boulot
à s'en prendre à ceux qui veulent
agressé nos policiers d'un jardin mais
il était nécessaire de créer une
nouvelle disposition qui viendra demain
au péché tout français de films et un
policier un gendarme est encore plus la
presse de faire son travail
donc moi je suis aujourd'hui très
méfiants face à ces propositions de loi
et ses projets de loi qui sont purement
et simplement liberticide
maxime thiébaut merci d'avoir répondu à
dos quelques mètres hauteur est docteur
en droit à mercin et vaux